journal de la rédaction henri sannier
bonsoir et bienvenue sur le plateau
d'antenne ne l à une ce soir marseille
où les enseignements d'une cantonale
partielle en prônant l'abstention
positif ce sont les termes de jean marie
le pen le front national donne un
avertissement à la majorité à six mois
des présidentielles
ouvert pour le sommer à gan gorbatchev à
genève messieurs chose de cher vana'diel
sont parvenues à un accord complet sur
les grandes lignes du traité sur les
euromissiles confirmation de la baisse
du chômage en france -1 1% en octobre
après -2% septembre les mesures de
traitement social du chômage explique la
décrue le secrétaire de la fédération
socialiste du rhône porte plainte pour
atteinte à la liberté individuelle
yvon deschamps avait été placé en garde
à vue dans le cadre de l' enquête sur
radio nostalgie la santé des marchés
financiers un geste européen après celui
des américains
les banques centrales allemande et
française baisse leurs taux d'intérêt
d'un quart de point
une journée supplémentaire de détention
pour marcel carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés
à quinze jours du sommet reggane
gorbatchev dont on parle beaucoup george
schultz et edouard chevardnadzé ont
conclu un accord cet après midi à genève
accords relatifs aux missiles de portée
intermédiaire et fameuse inf
les deux hommes ont confirmé la nouvelle
tout à l'heure au cours d'une conférence
de presse en parlant d' accord
historique
écoutez les devants la mission
américaine à genève messieurs schultz et
chez barnes et se sont serré la main
tout à l'heure et ont annoncé qu'après
quarante huit heures de discussions il
était maintenant d'accord sur tous les
problèmes qui se posaient encore un
traité sur l'élimination des missiles à
moyenne portée
traiter que mais serait qu'un et
gorbatchev pourront donc approuvé au
cours de leur rencontre de washington le
8 décembre prochain
alors si j'ai bien compris georges
bortoli le sommet ne sera plus qu'une
simple formalité simple entre guillemets
bien sûr bien sûr mais ses chaussures
messieurs reggane et gorbatchev les deux
numéros allons pas se rencontrer pour
discuter encore des détails du traité
ils vont se rencontrer pour comment
dirais-je pour officialiser ce traité
pour lui donner une existence tout à
fait éclatante officiel donc il va y
avoir dans quinze jours
la signature ce traité et après ça
qu'est ce qui va se passer eh bien il va
se passer que les soviétiques et les
américains vont se donner trois en trois
ans pour détruire tous leurs missiles à
moyenne portée ce qui veut dire que fin
1990 il ne devrait plus y avoir si tout
va bien
ni permis ni américain ni missiles de
croisière lancée du sol ni du côté
soviétique les grosses fusée ss20 à
trois têtes nucléaires tout ça devait
disparaître
mais après ces trois années de
destruction d'élimination il va falloir
des années pour vérifier que ça s'est
bien passé que là où l'autre ou là et
l'autre n'ont pas essayé de tourner le
traité il ya ses droits le plus facile
ça ne s'est pas que facile à tuzer que
tout a failli capoter jusqu'au dernier
moment
il y aura donc encore dix années
d'inspection mutuelle et réciproque ce
qui va tout de même nous mener jusqu'à
l'an 2000 un bail à marseille majorité
et front national se regardent en chiens
de faïence
au lendemain d'une élection cantonale à
laquelle tout le monde accorde une
valeur de test jean-marie le pen appelle
à l'abstention positive décision
importante car le candidat du front
national a recueilli plus de 18% des
suffrages jean marie le pen n'a
visiblement pas apprécié la déclaration
de françois léotard rejetant toute
alliance avec le front national
réflexion jean claude gaudin élus
marseillais caution du candidat de la
majorité
s'abstenir c'est favoriser la gauche le
dialogue de sourds en deux phrases
c'était ce matin à paris chez léotard en
rejetant toute alliance et tout accord
sous peine d'exclusion
avec le front national a montré qu'il
avait délibérément choisi la victoire de
la gauche dans ces conditions est temps
que durera cet ostracisme
il regrette de ne pouvoir apporter leur
soutien au candidat d'un parti qui veut
exclure du rassemblement national plus
que jamais nécessaire le front national
ses élus et ses électeurs non personne
ne détienne les clés pas plus monsieur
léotard que monsieur gaudin que monsieur
arrighi ou que monsieur le pen
il appartiendra aux électeurs qui ne
veulent pas voir revivre une expérience
socialo communistes dans notre pays
de se rassembler autour du candidat de
l'union de la majorité qui est largement
arrivé en tête au premier tour à
marseille réaction de michel peser au
nom du parti socialiste le piège se
referme sur jean claude gaudin at-il
déclaré tout à l'heure l'ancien
président du conseil régional provence
côte d'azur a ajouté que monsieur
léotard devait aller au bout de ses
propositions et inviter tous les
présidents de région à rompre avec le
front national
et de conclure on ne peut avoir un
discours à paris et adopter une attitude
contraire en région sociale le tassement
du chômage se confirme - 1 % en octobre
le ministère des affaires sociales a
officialisé le chiffre cet après midi
concrètement il y a deux millions cinq
cent soixante et onze mille 700
demandeurs d'emploi en octobre contre
deux millions cinq cent quatre-vingt
seize mille neuf cent en septembre
faites les comptes ça fait moins 25000
chauffe chômeurs pardon le taux de
chômage s'établit maintenant à 10,4 pour
cent alors deux mois de baisse
successive gérard leclerc est ce que
c'est vraiment significatif absolument
pour une bonne raison la machine du
traitement social du chômage tourne à
plein régime
rien qu'en octobre 80 mille jeunes sont
entrés en stage au total ils sont 900
mille la suivre une formation ou un
chèque alors cela coûte cher 10
milliards de francs mais les résultats
sont là 10% de demandeurs d'emploi en
moins chez les jeunes depuis cet été
l'effort porte également sur les
chômeurs de longue durée 55 mille sont
entrées en stage
alors grâce à cet arsenal il faudrait
également évoqué les radiations philippe
séguin espère retrouver au printemps 88
à la veille des élections
présidentielles le niveau de chômage de
mars 86 en cas de besoin a d'ailleurs
d'autres projets sont à l'étude comme
une formule d'exonération des charges
sociales pour l'embauché de chômeurs de
longue durée
l'activité économique un peu plus
soutenue que prévu également favorisé
l'embellie des statistiques les reprises
d'activité sont à la hausse et
globalement la france ne perd plus
d'emplois alors questions pratiques
gérard est ce que ça va continuer quand
il ya je crois deux points
d'interrogation que se passera-t-il
quand les jeunes en formation arriveront
en doute leur stage et socialiste évoque
une bombe à retardement du chômage ce
que conteste formellement bien sûr
philippe seguin
et puis il ya la menace d'un
ralentissement de l'économie après la
crise boursière et financière ce qui ne
manquerait pas d'avoir des répercussions
négatives sur l'emploi
merci
après la corse à qui il a accordé une
dotation supplémentaire de 200 millions
de francs jacques chirac l'a confirmé
cet après-midi les engagements en faveur
de la lorraine devant l'ensemble des
élus lorrains le premier ministre a
indiqué qu'un milliard deux cents
millions de francs de crédits publics
vont être engagés en faveur de la
lorraine il a confirmé la création de
deux nouvelles entreprises
une sud coréenne et une japonaise ces
deux entreprises créeront au minimum 430
emplois à lyon je vous le disais dès
hier soir la sphère de radio nostalgie
glisse de plus en plus sur le terrain
politique il se confirme que des fausses
factures de l'ordre d'un million de
francs ont servi à financer la campagne
du parti socialiste dans le département
du rhône
aujourd'hui le secrétaire de la
fédération du rhône du parti socialiste
contre attaque et il porte plainte
c'est le dernier épisode d'une affaire à
double détente à lyon en quête de
bernard pradines haut pour le procureur
de la république en conversation ici
avec les journalistes il ne faut pas
mélanger les choses
d'un côté je la sphère de radio
nostalgie escroquerie abus de biens
sociaux de l'autre la faire des fausses
factures grâce à une agence de publicité
lopes le parti socialiste du rhône
aurait ainsi financé une partie de sa
campagne électorale en 86 parmi les
sociétés qui auraient aidé le ps on
retrouve radio nostalgie j'ai rencontré
tout à l'heure monsieur yvon deschamps
le secrétaire de la fédération du rhône
du ps il a été mis en cause il est même
resté l'autre jours de midi à minuit au
palais de justice sans être entendu par
un juge
il a d'ailleurs ce soir porté plainte et
je lis dans la presse que de semblables
faits se seraient passés
il s'agit là je crois d'un problème
d'une actualité
réel puisque un certain nombre de
responsables de formations politiques
sont appelés par le premier ministre à
se rencontrer à ce propos alors pour ce
qui nous concerne entre ce que je lis
dans la presse et ce que l'on m'a montré
dans les locaux de la police judiciaire
j'ai vu là-bas des factures régulières
correspondant à des commandes
régulièrement passer régulièrement on ne
répare nous auprès d'une agence de
publicité j'ai vu d'autres factures qui
nous concerne pas dont je n'ai jamais
entendu parler voilà ce que je peux vous
dire ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
premier secrétaire de la fédération du
rhône du parti socialiste nous ne sommes
pas concernés par cette opération
voilà lé enquête de la police va durer
plusieurs jours
on est déjà bien loin de la sphère
n'aurait de nostalgie nous sommes en
fait en plein coeur de l'actualité et
pas loin d'une question de fond comment
rendre transparent le financement des
partis politiques
coïncidence en italie un professeur de
sciences politiques publient un livre
qui retrace un siècle d'histoire de la
corruption dans la péninsule tous les
partis politiques sont épinglés à des
degrés divers mais vous allez voir que
sur place c'est surtout la dc la
démocratie chrétienne qui trinquent
marcel trillât de 20s à une entreprise
qui marche
d'après ce 34 zola auteur d'une enquête
sur la corruption politique en italie où
devant et ça serait même au 12e rang des
entreprises italiennes chiffre
d'affaires annuel 60 milliards de francs
les hommes politiques italiens mettent
la main sur 50 millions de francs chaque
jour champion toutes catégories
la démocratie chrétienne avec 58% des
eaux chaudes table en très nette
progression depuis l'arrivée en force au
pouvoir à 83 de médecine au crack si le
parti socialiste avec 33%
les communistes en revanche ne recueille
que 3 % du gâteau mais les mauvaises
langues font remarquer que le professeur
cazzola l'auteur du livre et conseiller
municipal communiste de catane en sicile
il reconnaît pourtant que les deux seuls
partis apparemment jamais mouillé sans
le m
si néo fasciste et le parti radical qui
a d'autres ressources explication
probable ces deux organisations n'ont
accès ni au pouvoir central ni au
pouvoir régional lourd handicap pour se
faire acheter encore faut-il avoir
quelque chose à offrir en échange c'est
donnant donnant on peut se rassurer en
se disant au moins que la preuve en est
sa est en perte de vitesse c'est tout le
contraire
au cours des trois dernières années les
juges ont mis leur nez dans près de 7000
magouilles plus ou moins importantes
les partis politiques italiens
bénéficient par ailleurs d'un juteux
financement public et ils réussissent
pourtant le tour de force d'être pour la
plupart en déficit alors il faudrait en
conclure que les politiciens italiens
100 m purement et simplement plein les
poches
ça non c'est difficile à croire et
traders marcel la justice et à l'épreuve
depuis quelques temps en france on l'a
vu dans toutes les affaires qui font la
une de l'actualité un exemple la
mécanique de l'inculpation est l'objet
de bon nombre de réflexions et autres
interrogations
il faut bien constater qu'en france une
inculpation ternie souvent l'image de la
personne concernée
fort de cette constatation albin
chalandon le garde des sceaux va confier
à une commission le soin de réfléchir
sur la réforme de l'inculpation claude
crespo aujourd'hui est inculpé toute
personne soupçonnée d'avoir enfreint la
loi
un soupçon n'étant pas preuve de
culpabilité tout inculpé est donc
présumé innocent c'est le juge
d'instruction qui procède aux
inculpations
il appartient au tribunal de grande
instance est désigné pour trois ans et
possède un statut de magistrat
indépendant pour toute inculpation le
juge d'obtenir une réquisition une
autorisation du procureur de la
république premier magistrat du tribunal
de grande instance
ce dernier dépend directement du
ministère de la justice par
l'intermédiaire de son avocat l'inculpé
prend connaissance du dossier
d'instruction notamment des faits qui
lui sont reprochés
pour mieux se défendre au cours de son
enquête le juge peut entendre aussi les
témoins qui eux n'ont pas accès au
dossier tant qu'ils ne sont pas eux
mêmes inculpées selon la réforme
chalandon il ne serait plus nécessaire
d'être inculpé pour avoir accès au
dossier d'instruction
je crois que le problème de fond que
soulève le garde des sceaux c'est
qu'effectivement dans l'esprit du public
dans l'esprit des médias peut être un
peu aussi inculpation égale condamnation
ce qui n'est pas le cas je pense donc
éventuellement cette possibilité
pourrait modifier le cours des choses
mais que ça ne servira à rien si
lorsqu'on parle de témoin assisté
on souffre on sue tant qu'il s'agira
d'un inculpé et donc éventuellement d'un
condamné je crois que c'est surtout un
problème d'état d'esprit sur les marchés
financiers c'est la baisse concertée des
taux d'intérêt en europe qui tient la
vedette aujourd'hui la bundesbank a
donné le signal ce matin en diminuant
ses taux d'un quart de point
la banque de france a suivi en réduisant
également son taux d'escompté la baisse
généralisée du loyer de l'argent en
europe visait évidemment à faire
remonter le dollar sur le marché des
changes
c'est chose faite depuis cet après midi
quant à la bourse à paris eh bien là
clôturé à la hausse +3 78%
cette amorce de reprise est donc parti
d'allemagne elle est surtout le fruit
d'une coopération franco-allemande
philippe rochot l'allemagne fédérale
pourrait à présent baissé son taux
d'escompté c'est le bruit qui court à la
bourse de francfort où la baisse d'un
quart de point du taux de prise en
pension de la bundesbank a permis au
dollar de retrouver une certaine fermeté
sur le marché une décision qui restaure
la confiance puisque les cours dans
l'automobile ont gagné près de 30% alors
qu'ils étaient les plus attaquées au
début de la crise financière
par ces décisions l'allemagne fédérale
et son ministre des finances très tendu
la main aux états unis qui ont fait le
geste attendu à savoir la réduction de
leur déficit budgétaire que réclamait le
gouvernement de bonn
c'est une mesure efficace et crédible
s'il va instaurer la confiance sur le
marché des actions et des devises
c'est aussi la fin d'un bras de fer
entre bonnes et washington qui va
pousser l'allemagne à aller plus loin si
la même volonté de coopération existe
chez ses partenaires européens
l'amérique confronté à l'épineux
problème des réfugiés cubains depuis 48
heures les mutineries se succèdent en
louisiane puis en géorgie
les réfugiés se mutinent car ils
craignent d'être rapatrié à cuba pour
mieux comprendre la situation il faut
savoir qu'aux états unis la communauté
cubaine représente près d'un million de
personnes la plupart se sont très bien
intégrés
mais les autres ceux qui sont dans les
pénitenciers sont souvent
ancien repris de justice en privaient
fidel castro s'était d'ailleurs vanté
d'avoir joué un bon tour au gouvernement
américain il ya quelques années une
nouvelle révolte a éclaté aujourd'hui à
la prison en d'atlanta malgré les
déclarations apaisantes de ministre de
la justice paul nahon le ministre de la
justice à offrir de suspendre
temporairement la décision de rapatrier
dans leur pays d'origine ces cubains
indésirables aux états unis en louisiane
la garde nationale et l'armée sont en
état d' alerte un milliers de cubains
détiennent eux aussi 25 otage le
directeur de la prison vient d'affirmer
une attaque des locaux serait une lourde
erreur
les mutins de ces deux pénitenciers
n'ont pas de statut de citoyens
américains à part entière il refuse de
repartir à cuba plutôt rester en prison
jusqu'à la fin de leur vie utile
mais ici aux etats-unis avec bernard
benyamin nous allons essayer de mieux
cerner ces réfugiés cubains qui sont au
coeur de toutes les mutineries depuis 48
heures leur point de chute privilégié
demeure le new jersey et la région de
miami en floride mai 1980 des centaines
de bateaux se présente devant le port de
miami
ils viennent tous de cuba à leur bord
125 mille personnes que fidel castro a
laissé partir à la faveur d'une timide
libéralisation politique et qui vont
grossir les rangs de la colonie cubaine
installé depuis plus de 20 ans dans le
sud de la floride
ils sont partis la veille du petit port
de mariel dès lors ils seront pour tous
les mariés lite hausse
mais très vite les services
d'immigration découvre que parmi ces
nouveaux réfugiés se cache un grand
nombre de repris de justice c'est que
fidel castro a profité de cet exode pour
vider ses prisons conséquence mille me
va se transformer en une des villes les
plus dangereuses du monde et les mariés
littoz vont devenir synonyme de
criminels
et c'est vrai que le marché de la drogue
surtout de la cocaïne est devenu un
véritable monopole géré par les mariés
lite hausse chaque soir une dizaine de
petits pourvoyeurs sont arrêtés par la
police de miami
ils seront poursuivis pour détention
illégale d'armes
autant dire que selon la juridiction
américaine dans deux jours
ils seront libres la prison du comté 2
days c'est ici que se retrouvent toutes
les personnes appréhendées dans les bars
du centre-ville ou dans leur voiture
c'est le cas des mariés lite hausse
comme cet homme sorti semble t-il tout
droit d'un film noir des années 50 et
qui en est à sa troisième arrestation
cette fois c'est plus sérieux on l'a
trouvé en possession d'un sachet de
cocaïne
et c'est ici qu'il va attendre son
procès
dans une atmosphère lourde de cris et de
chaleur
des dizaines de suspects attend ainsi
des heures leur passage à la douche ou à
l'identification
certains étant encore sous le coup de
leur voyage assuré par une seringue en
intraveineuse
les cinq personnes sont maintenant amy
mbaye à aiacciu et comme veste ou tout
photo roi qu'est l'amérique dans leurs
tâches murmure-t-on porter une part à
quiconque et bayrou en même temps mais
où ça permet pas bien
4 6 6 4 6 4
les télégrammes de l'étranger avec
pascal vanier ensuite nous partirons à
la découverte d'un salon pas tout à fait
comme les autres
au bourget des commandos armés saccage
incendie et eu à port au prince quatre
morts en deux nuits 30 blessés tension
extrême à cinq jours des élections
présidentielle et législatives
selon des témoins plusieurs agresseurs
se réclamait de l'ex président duvalier
accueillis par 2000 supporteurs
guillermo hugo de retour lui aussi au
salvador après la mifi le chef du front
démocratique révolutionnaire entend
participer au plan de paix en amérique
centrale
le président salvadorien à duarte
demande à gages à hugo et ses amis
couper leurs liens avec la guérilla du
pays interdiction totale de fumer dans
le métro londonien y compris aux entrées
au guichet première mesure après le
drame de king's cross 30 personnes ont
péri mercredi dans un incendie pour les
enquêteurs c'est en toute vraisemblance
un mégot qui embrasait des détritus
ramassés sous un escalier mécanique 200
tonnes de vache sera interdite à la
vente et fabrication arrêté jusqu'à
nouvel ordre dans le canton de vaud
incriminé la croûte du fromage et elle
seule à l'intérieur une bactérie cause
d'intoxication et peut être même de
décès les suisses avance 30 personnes en
deux ans et services de santé français
effectuent des prélèvements pour se
prémunir d'une épidémie similaire au
bourget dans la région parisienne
ouverture de milipol milipol c'est le
supermarché et de la sécurité dans les
rayons les spécialistes internationaux
des problèmes de sécurité peuvent
découvrir les derniers produits pour
lutter contre la criminalité
quinze mille mètres carrés de storm plus
de 300 exposants et un arsenal à faire
frémir les terroristes les plus endurcis
patrice pollet
le salon milipol c'est un peu le rendez
vous de ceux qui un jour appuieront
peut-être sur la gâchette policiers
militaires agents spéciaux gardes du
corps ils sont là pour essayer le
matériel posé toutes les questions et
éventuellement bien sûr pas c'est
comment la gâchette est très bonne
la détente est très bonne et
me paraît intéressant et pas chère à
faire la tendance des dernières années
des armes courtes avec visée laser une
société belge propose la plus petite
visée laser du monde
un tube de quelques centimètres par
illumination il projette un point rouge
sur la cible 100% de réussite
même pour ceux qui n'ont jamais tiré un
coup de feu de leur vie on vient de loin
pour visiter ce salon ici des saoudiens
essaye un fusil d'assaut
malgré toutes leurs qualités ces armes
ne parviennent pas à transpercer ce
vitrage et ça ça intéresse certains
autres clients je me suis renseigné sur
du matériel détection des explosifs
sur de l'antigone pour des raisons un
peu particulières propres à l'activité
de ne pas fatiguer l'antigone settat
matériau qui n'est pas du verre et qui
empêchent des impacts fin le passage de
certaines balles avis aux manifestants
dans quelques semaines ce camion anti
émeute entièrement blindés sera dans la
rue une caméra vidéo sera là pour vous
filmez souriez et 7000 litres d'eau
colorée à disposition pour vous
rafraîchir les idées pour finir le robot
démineur télécommandé pour lui comme
pour nous espérons qu'un jour il servira
offert des fleurs oui à défaut de fleurs
josé j'aurais aimé vous offrir un canon
contre les intempéries a priori si raté
il ya dernier dans l'arsenal mais je ne
veux pas à bon compte en veux pas
un canon à neige vous imaginez on n'a
pas besoin en ce moment c'est une
mauvaise idée
les nuages on provoquerait la pluie et
on n'a pas besoin nous alors j'abandonne
on a besoin d'un satellite ça nous donne
les images que voici
facile donc des images alors pour demain
tout de même sachez que la situation
reste à peu près inchangées mais tout de
même un petit peu moins depuis un petit
peu moins de neige
voici donc une perturbation qui continue
de s'enrouler de tourner en rond
au-dessus de la france à leurs résultats
pour demain un petit peu plus de nuages
sur la moitié nord donc avec des pluies
est depuis un peu moins importante avec
des vents des vents forts tout même sur
le vent de nord-est sur la manche tout
le l'ouest eh bien ce sera sous les
nuages sont pluie toutefois mais de la
neige sur les pyrénées
enfin tout le flanc est lui verra le
retour du soleil enfin soleil tout
timide tout de même et toujours de la
neige en montagne quelques averses ou la
côte d'azur encore les températures
continuent de chuter un degré par jour à
peu près puisqu'il fera 5 degrés à paris
demain 4 à strasbourg et 8 à bray sur la
moitié sud
3° à limoges et 10 degrés de nice à
perpignan voilà demain mercredi 25
novembre
eh bien ce sera la sainte catherine et
puis sainte catherine est aussi bonne
fête josé c'est pour demain un an près
oui ce fut une couche tôt excusez-moi
cusco en exclusivité sur antenne 2 le
commandant cousteau et notre président
claude contamine viennent de signer un
accord qui nous permettra de diffuser
une série de vince in de 50 minutes
intitulé à la découverte du monde
l'accord s'est concrétisée hier soir aux
etats unis à new york au moment même où
le commandant cousteau recevait le prix
de l'académie internationale de
télévision
bientôt sur antenne 2 ces images
extraordinaires tourné par l'équipe du
commandant cousteau qui réserve à notre
chaîne d'exclusivité d'une nouvelle
série télévisée
vingt films haïti cuba les îles
marquises la grande barrière de corail
la chine
le temps d'une soirée le commandant
cousteau a délaissé la calypso pour se
rendre à new york où il a signé le
contrat avec le pdg d'antenne 2 claude
contaminé
jacques yves cousteau a poussé un
nouveau cri d'alarmé sur la pollution de
notre planète et les éléments les plus
touchés l'eau et l'air c'est à dire les
deux flûtes de la vie c'est plus le
reste je voulais lolll l'eau douce bien
sûr mais l'odm a également commencé à
l'heure actuelle à être d'une qualité
très inférieure et l'air que nous
respirons est complètement peut lui
alors entre les deux il est certain que
la vie devient de plus en plus précaire
commandant cousteau a développé depuis
des années une forme de communication
grâce à la télévision qui touchent le
grand public et qui apporte aux gens
publics des éléments d'information une
infection sur des problèmes sérieux qui
concerne notre monde sont l'avenir ce
que le commandant cousteau à la fois
montre et c'est qu'on prend
au cours de la série sur cuba vous
verrez la rencontre au sommet entre
fidel castro et le commandant cousteau
ils ont parlé cigare bien sûr
environnement mais aussi politique
et hier soir à new york
consécration le commandant cousteau a
reçu la plus haute distinction des
télévisions américaines
un emmy award pour l'ensemble de son
oeuvre
prochain rendez vous d'information avec
aubry et de l'air à 23h30 24 heures
dernière demain 24 heures sur l'a 2
demain à 6h45 n'oubliez pas télématin
avec roger zabel catherine ceylac les
marques hautement merci de votre
fidélité et à demain à 20 heures pour le
journal d'antenne 2